mit vielen fällen werde typischer
gesehen wir erwarten heute wieder
rückwärts und zwar machen wir jetzt so
dass eine person das ist in diesem fall
wieder aufnimmt aufmärsche und ihnen
auch rückwärts abspielen und vorspielen
müssen erraten weg sieht das ist der
gewinner gewinnen der zweite gewinner
gewinnt auch aber der verlierer frist
also mal entspannt einläuten
die mitstreitern heutigen tage und zwar
heißt das kecke alles klar die maus
bereichert damit raus wird nur den
ersten vom bitte
fotolia verständigt dass techno dafür
weiwei infokasten zusammen wer trägt
dafür
[Musik]
alles okay nicht besorgt
ich habe mich rum geräte weil ich den
namen von dem hier liegen heute wie
heidfeld noch mal mit ihm
doch man kann man gemacht dort kam ein
gesundes klima aber das einleben
deswegen richtig gesagt bekommen also
wäre es alles punkte katar in 2003
drei junge leute nur für euch jetzt
schon bei drei jahren gerade mal ein
leichter aber mach mal irgendwie du
warst nur bewundern können
[Musik]
bitteschön später gewinn von 5 ich habe
mich die letzten raten das heißt steht 1
3 0 1 und das heißt die bestrafung in
diesem fall an mich geht wer machen
kameramann leute hier persönlichen
aufgemacht und die oben bekommt ihr
natürlich für euch vorschlages video
amerika abonnieren und hier oben
heute folge verlassen